لطالما أرادت مارلينا ستيل و إيه دي سيلفا
أخًا أو أختًا
صغيرة لابنتهما أديلينا بدلاً من ذلك ، كان ما
حصلوا عليه بمثابة كابوس بسبب
قانون مكافحة الإجهاض في تكساس ،
فأنا
غاضب جدًا
لدرجة أنني عوملت بهذه الطريقة بسبب
القوانين التي تم تمريرها.  من قبل رجال
لم يسبق لهم الحمل ولن يكونوا أبدًا
كابوسًا ممتازًا بدأ كحلم
أصبح حقيقة بعد شهور من محاولة
حملها في أواخر الصيف الماضي ، كنا
متحمسين للغاية لأننا لم نعتقد
أنه يمكنني الحمل ولكن في الموجات فوق الصوتية
لمدة أسبوعين  قالت لاحقًا إنه لا
يوجد نبض قلب ولا يوجد حمل قابل للحياة
طلبت ستيلا من طبيبها علاجًا قياسيًا.
قال حسنًا بسبب القانون الجديد
الذي تم تمريره ،
سيتعين عليك الحصول على
الموجات فوق الصوتية الأخرى حتى أتمكن من فعل
أي شيء من أجلك
مرهقًا عاطفيًا وجسديًا
سيصبح الألم شديدًا لدرجة أنه سيكون من
الصعب المشي ، ذهبت للحصول على
الموجات فوق الصوتية الغازية الثانية في مركز تصوير
ووصفها لاحقًا في مقطع فيديو على YouTube ، قام
شخص ما بدفع عصا في منطقتي الحساسة
وأخبرني مرحبًا أنك فقدت طفلك
مرة أخرى.  لا يجب أن تمر
بذلك مرتين ، لذا كان عليك أن تسمعها
مرتين لأنك فقدت طفلًا ، لقد شعرت بالانزعاج ،
أنا آسف ،
هذا جيد
لأنك تعرف بالفعل ما
ستراه ،
إنه مثل رؤيته مرتين يتم
إخبارك بذلك  لن تكوني أماً
حتى بعد الموجات فوق الصوتية الثانية ،
فهل سيعطيك طبيب التوليد الإجراء الجراحي ،
فلا
داعي للذهاب إلى فحص آخر
بالموجات فوق الصوتية يظهر جنينها الميت ، لذا
كنت تتجول
وتحمل جنينًا ميتًا وتحمله عاطفيًا
.  مجرد معرفة أنه
لا يوجد شيء يمكنك القيام به ،
أشعر فقط أنه لا يمكنني الحزن أو
تجاوزه لأنني أتجول فقط أحمله ، لقد كانت الدكتورة ليليان شابيرو من النساء في
أتلانتا لأكثر من 3  0 سنة
عندما تتجول امرأة مع
جنين ميت
لأسابيع لأنها لا تستطيع إجراء
عملية جراحية ،
ما هو الخطر عليها؟ يمكن أن
تصاب بعدوى يمكن أن تجعلها عقيمة
وغير قادرة على
الإنجاب مرة أخرى أو حتى أسوأ من الطفل
يموت داخل الطفل يبدأ في إطلاق
أجزاء من أنسجته التي يمكن أن تصل
إلى إمداد دم الأم ، ويمكن أن يتسبب
ذلك في فشل الأعضاء ويمكن أن يتسبب
في الوفاة في تكساس وبعض الولايات الأخرى.
في دعوى قضائية باهظة الثمن ، يمكن
لأي مواطن أن يسير في
المحكمة ويقول أعتقد أن الدكتور سميث أجرى عملية
إجهاض ويتم تحفيز المواطنين
على رفع مثل هذه القضايا يمكنهم الفوز بأكثر
من 10 آلاف دولار وحتى عندما
يتمكن الأطباء من إثبات وفاة الجنين ،
لا يزال الطبيب  يجب أن يكونوا مسؤولين عن
الرسوم القانونية الخاصة بهم التي
سيخسرونها على الرغم من
فوزهم وهذا هو التأثير المخيف الذي يواجهونه
هذا الشبح من الدمار الذي لا نهاية له.
أخبرني
بأنهم لا يستطيعون التوقف ، لا
يمكنهم تجنبهم لا يمكنهم استباق الأمر
لأنني تحدثت بشكل ممتاز ، فكرت في
كيفية
حدوث إجهاض تم التعامل معه
بشكل مختلف تمامًا بين أطفالي الثاني والثالث ، ورأوا أنه لم يكن هناك
دقات قلب  هل فعلت dnc ،
فقد سمحت لي بالمضي قدمًا بسرعة
والحمل مرة أخرى ثم حملت
مرة أخرى بشكل صحيح جدًا وهذا شيء رائع
وهذه هي القصة التي نريد أن نسمعها
من الأشخاص المتميزين لم تكن محظوظة جدًا لأنها
تمكنت أخيرًا من العثور على طبيب
لأداء dnc الخاص بها ولكن الأمر استغرق أسبوعين
وهي تخشى أن
يحدث لها الكابوس مرة أخرى ، هل تحاول
الحمل مرة أخرى ،
لا لماذا لا أشعر بالقلق من الإصابة
، حدث لي شيء ثم
تركت ابنتي بدون والدتها
الآن هم  يفكرون في الابتعاد
عن تكساس بعيدًا عن عائلتهم الممتدة
فقط حتى يتمكنوا من محاولة
الحمل مرة أخرى إليزابيث كوهين
CNroe texas